[Music]  you wanna go where the action ends you  wanna break the night we're over some of  your about the way you give no thought  of where you'll go  [Music]  oh boy you're gonna win you bring  everything that everyone they like your  life it's for the bear if you look  inside you'll come on down I'm just  trying to scratch the server under your  skin  [Music]  Sakana not too bad your screen  [Music]  when you feel too much so I could take  it to the place we were scared  [Music]  which is mine  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  without your father  [Music]  you  [Music]  to calm your nerves  [Music]  [Applause]  to save way to save you from yourself  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  you